officials in the Houston area are
investigating a deadly police shooting
caught on video last night the cell
phone video posted on social media shows
a Baytown Texas police officer firing
five shots after struggling to arrest a
45 year old woman nikki batise is
covering this still unfolding story and
joins us at the table the video we've
seen so far is very disturbing it's
extremely disturbing Gail
police say the 11-year veteran was
apparently doing a routine patrol
outside of an apartment complex when he
came across a woman who he knew had
outstanding warrants we must warn you
the video you are about to see can be
disturbing to some viewers this cell
phone video begins as the officer
confronts the woman as she moves away
from the bay town officer he pulls out
his taser and fires the woman continues
to struggle with the officer as she
falls to the ground at one point telling
him she's pregnant she then according to
police gains control of the officers
taser turning it on him that's when he
fires his gun at the woman five times
she was pronounced dead at the scene
heard the gunshots and then all of a
sudden I heard the ambulance seen
anything like this five after a five
years staying here this is you saw the
woman frequently walking her dog in the
area say they believe she may have had
mental issues sometimes you would see
her you know get into it with people
around the apartment just typical her
she's not a bad person she didn't hurt
nobody
investigators say the officer was out
doing a routine patrol when he got out
of his car to approach the woman
lieutenant Steve Doris of the Baytown
Police Department says a preliminary
investigation found it was necessary for
the officer to use deadly force our
officer got tased with his own taser
if somebody's tasing you whether it
takes your taser away from you and
starts tasing you there's a very good
likelihood they're just gonna escalate
and get very very bad for the officer
from there a witness also said the
officer lives in the same complex police
say the officer was wearing a body
camera but that video will not be
released yet
the district
News Office is investigating the
shooting along with the bay town police
and that officer is now on three days
leave according to policy terrible
morticians they're you know very
disturbing thank you very much thank you